k
[Música]
Boa noite a todos já vamos
iniciar eu esqueci de pegar o fone de
ouvido aqui para conectar no microfone
vocês estão me ouvindo
bem vou aguardar alguém me dar o
feedback de como é que tá o áudio pra
gente poder
continuar como é que está o áudio
Alexandre boa noite
[Música]
vocês podem me dar um feedback do áudio
pra gente poder continuar
aqui ótimo áudio Obrigado Estela sim bom
som ótimo nós só temos duas perguntas tá
E ontem eu tava viajando voltei ontem de
viagem e não consegui separar material
de artigos Mas eu posso fazer isso agora
mas antes vamos responder
dúvidas eu vou simplesmente pegar aqui
as
dúvidas que são duas dúvidas da Eliane
Vou colocar aqui num documento para
ficar mais fácil para
vocês visualizarem
[Música]
apresentar
aqui esse
aqui
pronto ué não tá aparecendo pera aí tem
que mexer
aqui tá em tabela tem que tirar da
tabela se eu fizer assim pronto já
resolv
[Música]
Pronto agora já D
apresentar eu vou primeiro responder à
dúvidas do documento depois responde à
dúvidas do Eliseu ao vivo
Ok vamos lá
[Música]
apresentação pronto
eu acho que tá dando para ver bem
né primeira pergunta Em que casos é
indicado o glifage Em que casos é
indicado o glifage
XR as duas perguntas que eu vou
responder agora s da Eliane Eliane tá ao
vivo hum não parece tá ao vivo Então
temos o Alexandre a Alice
Vogel O
Eliseu vamos
lá bem que que é o grifagem é a
metiformina né um medicamento super
conhecido contra
diabetes diabet tipo do utilizado também
para casos de anti agem ele já é
estudado há mais de 10 anos para atrasar
o
envelhecimento apesar de ter alguns
problemas inerentes aí mas ele também é
utilizado no pré-diabetes e na
resistência
insulínica Nós consideramos a
metiformina a primeira opção para
pacientes com excesso de peso ou
obesidade ou resistência insulínica ou
pré-diabetes ele ajuda a reduzir a
produção de glicose pelo fígado tem uma
ação também intestinal na no microbiota
ajudando a a modular o microbiota isso
também tem um efeito de baixar o açúcar
e o terceiro efeito dele é a melhora da
sensibilidade a insulina o glifage XR
nada mais é do que a metiformina de
liberação prolongada ele é utilizado em
situações que o paciente tem mais
sintomas tem mais efeitos colaterais e
os principais são os gastrointestinais a
diarreia e náuseas Porque como a
liberação dele é lenta não é de uma vez
só a pessoa atende a ter Menos efeitos
colaterais E além disso ele garante um
controle mais constante da glicemia ao
longo do dia a maioria dos médicos hoje
prescrevem direto o XR Até onde eu sei
Ok vamos falar um pouquinho sobre o que
nós podemos fazer naturalmente Além da
metiformina né a berberina eu acho que
vocês já me ouviram falar várias vezes a
respeito ela age muito parecido com a
metiformina mas no meu entendimento é
mais vantajoso porque também ajuda a
baixar glicérides ou triglicerídeos
então ajuda equilibrar as gorduras do
sangue e também tem um efeito modulador
de flora intestinal a berberina pode ser
utilizada para tratamento aí de
intestino irritável diarreia
crônica Mas além do uso da berberina tem
vários outros picolin Cromo tem o
vanádio tem um extrato
de canela também ajuda bastante você tem
aí o alho
envelhecido também ajuda muito e fazer
uma dieta adequada reduzindo
carboidratos especialmente os refinados
o açúcar aumentando a fibra que tem nos
legumes nas folhas e também aumentando
as gorduras saudáveis que tem nas nozes
abacate e
azeite uso da vitamina D de dado também
ajuda a melhorar a resistência
insulínica vitam bed dado além de baixar
a pressão arterial também ajuda a
reduzir a a resistência aumentar a
sensibilidade insulínica atividade
física você estão cansados de ouvir eu
falando né especialmente treem de força
e
caminhada o gengibre também ajuda a
controlar o vinagre de maçã que eu já
falei várias
vezes então tem várias medidas
aí a próxima
pergunta tomar T4 T3 com vitamina C
seria mais eficiente eu falei já isso em
vídeos tá isso é uma coisa que até se
você pesquisar dependendo da fonte que
você pesquisa pode falar coisas
diferentes tá e alguns lugares vão te
falar que a vitamina C não deve ser
tomada junto com T4 e T3 porque vai
atrapalhar a absorção mas existe estudos
mostrando que a vitamina C tende a
favorecer a absorção dos hormônios
tiroidianos especialmente no contexto do
uso do T4 level tiroxin tá que que
acontece o mecanismo principal é a
capacidade da vitamina C de reduzir o ph
gástrico ou seja tornar o PH gástrico
mais ácido o que pode melhorar a
dissolução e absorção do hormônio teve
um estudo que foi realizado com
pacientes que apresentavam dificuldade
de absorção Esse estudo demonstrou que a
adição de 1 g de vitamina C junto com T4
lev tiroxina resultou numa redução
significativa dos níveis de TSH
sugerindo uma melhora na
biodisponibilidade desse
hormônio só que existe a questão que os
estudos que falam que a vitamina se
ajuda na absorção do T4 ainda são
limitados em
números alguns resultados apresentaram
variações
existe por exemplo estudos que avaliou o
uso do T4 com alimentos naturalmente
ricos em vitamina C como
grapefruit e nesse caso o uso da fruta
rico em vitamina C não ajudou na
absorção do T4 ou seja então eu não
recomendo que vocês usam camu camu ou
grip fru ou limão mas sim a vitamina C
isolada para aumentar a absorção do T4 e
algumas pessoas é bem conhecido doses
altas de vitamina C pode dar diarreia
pode dar desconforto gastrointestinal
Então tem que ser visto caso a caso né
então se a colocar
aqui os pró e contras da vitamina C como
eu falei a vitamina C aumenta a acidez
baixa o PH do estômago isso aumenta a
absorção por causa da aumento da
dissolução da levotiroxina porém doses
excessivas vão dar desconforto
gastrointestinal tem estudos
demonstrando claramente a redução dos
níveis de TSH quando você usa a vitamina
C junto com a lev tiroxin T4 isso tá
sugerindo a melhora da absorção do
hormônio mais estudos são limitados
que os resultados podem variar de pessoa
a
pessoa e existe também a potencial
interação da Vitamina C com outros
medicamentos então isso tem que ser
levado em consideração
também bem Vamos as perguntas ao vivo
Deixa eu tirar aqui
pronto el eu pergunto aqui qual é o nome
da ca mais indicada para a cicatrização
de
feridas que passaram por
sutura olha dizer o que eu Sao não
existe essa Cepa específica para
cicatrização de feridas não não conheço
essa
informação se você viu isso em algum
lugar você me fala que eu vou atrás
dessa informação mas eu nunca vi uma
Cepa específica para cicatrização de de
feridas não de
probiótico o tamanho da micose de unha
serve como Termômetro da
candidíase mais ou menos Eliseu mais ou
menos não é linear assim não
tá em outras palavras quanto maior a
micose da unha do
dedão maior a quantidade de
candidíase não pois é isso que é o ponto
né Não dá para concluir dessa forma
é óbvio que se pessoa tiver muita micose
de
unha existe aí com certeza uma maior
disbiose isso tá correlacionado à
Cândida intestinal só que não é uma
coisa linear tá pode ter uma pessoa que
tem por exemplo micose numa unha só e
ter mais disbiose intestinal do que uma
outra pessoa que tem micose nas duas
unhas por exemplo Então não é linear não
tá é sugestivo mas não é linear
perguntei sobre a necessidade de fazer o
exame de dímero para coágulos causado
pela proteína Spike
eh você perguntou no documento porque
não não tá aqui não não mas eu vou
responder agora não tem
problema então o dímero primeiro ele não
é específico para checar eh
a questão do Spike tá a gente não tem um
exame específico para isso infelizmente
a gente tem que ver se isso vai existir
Espero que exista porque isso é muito
muito importante então a gente acaba
usando Dedim de uma forma indireta
porque ele é um marcador de coagulação
intravascular o problema do Dedim é que
ele não aumenta só com coagulação ele
aumenta com inflamação ele aumenta
com
câncer então ele é inespecífico esse é
um grande problema do dímero tá então eu
tenho muitos muitos pacientes que tem
dímero acima de 1000 que a gente fica
sem saber o que fazer porque assim eu
passo doses baixas gente com ambulante
porém a gente não tem um critério
Eh claro de parar o Quando parar o no
caso o charelton né o a rivaroxabana que
eu mais uso e muitos pacientes Não temm
uma queda do Dedo fica meses ou anos com
dedo alto então isso é um grande drama
no dia a dia
Na verdade eu peço dímero para pessoas
que eu suspeito que possa ter problemas
a relacionados a proteí Spike seja
natural seja induzida né Você sabe pelo
que
eh mas isso é uma coisa que causa muito
problema hoje em dia ainda porque a
gente não sabe quando parar o
anticoagulante porque o Dedim muitas
vezes ele não ele não cai mesmo tomando
o anticoagulante ou ele cai e sobe de
novo esse é um problema né então eu Fari
assim o exame de dímero mesmo com os
problemas que ele tem né de não ser
preciso em todo mundo que tomou né os
imunizantes
e também quem teve a doença natural quer
dizer natural ainda mod de falar que a
gente sabe que o vírus não tem nada de
natural né mas essa é outra
história mas tem esse problema aí tem
muita gente que acaba tendo que ficar
tomando por muito tempo porque a gente
não tem um critério Claro de
parada não sei se eu respondi tua
pergunta Alice
mas se ficou dúvidas ainda pode se
manifestar aqui tá ao
vivo sobre vitamina B2 Existem algumas
pessoas que T uma maior demanda sim
existem Alexandre existe
sim digamos assim o organismo gasta mais
sim existe pessoas que o organismo gasta
mais
B12 isso existe tá E existe pessoas que
TM dificuldade de absorver a B1 que é o
pessoal que tem anemia perniciosa né
anemia que tá relacionado à atrofia
gástrica tá relacionado à doença
autoimune né que é a gastrite
atrófica Então esse pessoal tem muita
dificuldade de absorver bedos e outro
grupo também é o grupo de bariátricos
que fizeram a cirurgia bariátrica n e
mas tem um grupo que absorve normal mas
a demanda de B2 é maior sim tá
especialmente se tá se recuperando de
uma cirurgia você tá tendo que ter maior
produção de células brancas células
vermelhas porque sofr um trauma Então
existe isso assim que você tá falando
tá isso é muito comum também Alexandre
quando as pessoas vão envelhecendo é o
meu caso também eu tenho uma tendência
muito forte a minha B 12 cair rápido eu
também tenho esse mesmo problema que
você eu tenho que ficar muito atento a
minha B12 para ela ficar em níveis
ótimos porque ela cai com muita
frequência porque o trato gastro
intestinal já não tá absorvendo com a
mesma eficiência Mesmo não tendo anemia
perniciosa mesmo tendo garete atrófica
eh isso acontece com muita gente é o meu
caso por
exemplo Como saber se a síndrome fúndica
está definitivamente curada não tem um
exame exato Eliseu é uma é uma mistura
de
clínica com ou seja os sintomas da
pessoa os sinais e sintomas com
evidências indiretas que não tem mais
como é que seria evidência indireta
seria a parte imunológica você pedir o
IgG o IGM de Cândida no sangue e cair né
Essa é uma evidência indireta ou você
pedir um exame de função intestinal um
comprom Max um compro lógico funcional
estendido e não ter mais os marcadores
inflamatórios aumentados
Tá então não tem exame específico tem
exames
indiretos a partir de que valor de
referência de rdw preocupante geralmente
acima de 13% tá porque que esse aí é um
marcador tá
eh de quanto que as células vermelhas
estão saindo padronizadas né então se as
células vermelhas estão saindo com
uma grande variação de formato né
imagina uma fábrica de prato né E essa
fábrica de prato tem que soltar o prato
Tudo do mesmo tamanho e aí deu um
problema na fábrica e um prato sai 13 cm
outro sai 12 outro sai 10 ficar essa
bagunça aí não sai padrão
Então esse rtw é exatamente isso ele é
um parâmetro de homogeneidade de tamanho
de massa quando ele tá muito alto
significa que as emass estão vindo de
vários tamanhos diferentes e isso é ruim
tá é um marcador de doença então o
limite seria por volta de 13 tá o
rdw Quais são as vacinas indicadas para
pessoas acima de
60 olha uma pergunta que tá cada vez
mais difícil de responder porque se a
gente for pelo calendário né cada ano
aumenta
mais mas hoje eu tenho muita muita
cautela com vacinas né vacina por
exemplo de meninas não é não é da sua
idade né idade menina aí de nove até 13
anos de idade e eles recomendam usar
vacina de HPV Só que tem uma associação
lá no norte de meninas com lesões
neurológicas por conta disso aí
né ao acho tem que tomar cuidado que eu
tô falando aqui para não bloquear o
vídeo
eh mas enfim o que eu te recomendo é que
você se você teve por exemplo uma outra
doença não não é mais o caso do HPV HPV
é para mulheres em idade reprodutiva
mais né agora você teve Oster né que é o
vírus da varicelas sster aí eu
recomendo que se você obter uma vacina
com a
tecnologia comum né não é RNA não é
adenovírus não tem genética envolvida aí
eu tomaria essa Vacina se você teve
alguma crise de herpis
Hoster agora já não sou fã por exemplo
da vacina da gripe eu acho ela muito
ruim assim do ponto de vista ter ficar
tomando todo ano eu acho que é um
estresse éo sistema imune todo ano tomar
essa vacina acho ela pouco eficaz eu
acho que é muito mais interessante você
ficar tomando vitamina D de dado zinco
se tiver deficiência magnésio
e também manter essa vitamina D3 K2 em
níveis adequados como eu já falei a B12
também
importante e então isso é muito mais
interessante do que ficar tomando trocas
vacinas Tá bom eu sei que isso é muito
polêmico Mas é uma opinião que eu tenho
a respeito que eu acho que tem que ser
visto com muita tranquilidade com muita
cautela cada uma dessas vacinas aí então
Eh então recapitulando que tá a a de
gripe eu não recomendo a de pneumococos
né que é muito
utilizada também tem muito caso de
idosos que tem pneumonia né por
pneumococos essa de pneumococos eu
também tenho que ver caso a caso né Eu
acho que tem que melhorar o sistemo
imune da pessoa antes de pensar em em
dar mas eu não acho errado da de
pneumococos pneumo eh
[Música]
já falei da gripe já falei
da varicela zoster né do Oster e que
mais que tem tem aquela vacina Também
meningocócica Também acho tem que ver
caso a caso tá se deveria se vale a pena
não
utilizar se você for PR uma áa endêmica
que tem e FEB amarela eu acho que vale a
pena tomar porque ela é uma vacina bem
tranquila assim não tem tem um visto
complicações
Então é isso aí eu não tô lembrando mais
de nenhuma que seja específica para
idosos hepatite b não é específica para
idosos Mas se for profissional da área
de saúde que trabalha com sangue com
secreções eu acho que vale a pena
[Música]
tomar ã mas não é uma vacina específica
para idosos
Pois é blandon infelizmente isso é bem
comum
tá deixa eu ver aqui eu posso est
esquecendo de alguma vacina aqui Elane
Deixa eu olhar aqui
rapidamente já te falo
aquição
instante ver se eu esqueci alguma vacina
tá já falei da póa que tá aqui já falei
de influenza que é da
gripe já falei da herps
hepatite B já falei febre amarela já
falei Aí fica faltando o vírus ccial
respiratório eu acho que Esso Aqui só
deve ser dado em pessoas que são muito
vulneráveis também que não é não deveria
dar de de rotina como eu te falei muito
mais importante vitamina D o zinco e
magnésio do que ficar toda hora tomando
esses negócios
tem a questão da vacina Tríplice de
feria tetno cokeluche essa daqui a cada
10 anos não é uma vacina específica para
quem tem 60 ou mais mas essa aqui eu
acho que é tranquila de tomar essa
vacina é muito antiga nunca vi problema
com
ela
é é o cobrir tudo S Só faltou a tríplice
viral né tríplice viral que é sarampo
cachumba e rubéola
mas só para quem tá em áreas endêmicas
né então é isso acho que eu respondi bem
essa
pergunta uma pessoa pode ter doenças
psiquiátricas por causa da cirurgia
bariátrica eu acho se ela tiver uma
predisposição anterior e ficar com
muitas deficiências nutricionais Sim ela
pode desenvolver uma psiquiátrica depois
da bariátrica se ela não repos esses
nutrientes
tá perfeitamente possível especialmente
vitaminas no complexo B A vitamina B de
bola 3 tem um efeito importante na parte
de
eh essa parte
psiquiátrica a vitamina C tem
importância a vitamina D tem importância
magnésio tem importância o zinco tem
importância o cobre tem importância
então é bem é possível sim que uma
pessoa com predisposição possa
desenvolver uma C psiquiátrica se não
repos nutrientes porque ela vai ficar
deficiente depois da cirurgia variada
Boa noite Cristina seja
bem-vinda isso pema essa daí eu acho que
é válida sim dependendo do
caso pcg
hepatite tá falando deve ser a né porque
eles não dão de bem recé nascido nesse
caso BCG que seria tuberculose sim vale
a pena tá são vacinas convencionais
vale a pena
sim deficiência de ferro pode fazer a
rdw subir para o valor de
24 pode Eliane Pode
sim Isso é perfeitamente possí
bem deixa eu achar um artigo aqui para
discutir com vocês aqui
bem Tem um artigo aqui falando sobre uso
da vitamina K pro tratamento de
ã câimbras noturnas nas
pernas tem mais perguntas aqui do
blandon qual uma dose legal de betaína
termiti glicina para baixar uma cí de 15
em adulto jovem usa 500 mg duas vezes ao
dia é muito seguro tá trimi o glicina é
muito muito seguro não tem praticamente
contraindicação você pode usar 2 3 G por
dia sem menor problema mas eu começaria
com 500 mg duas vezes ao
dia me digam se vocês querem que a gente
mude alguma coisa nesses nossos
encontros semanais se vocês não
querem porque assim eu tentei algumas
vezes puxar alguns de vocês para fazer
assim uma espécie de talk show né
conversar com alguns de vocês durante as
lives ao vivo e trocar uma ideia aí
mas sempre teve a questão todo mundo
ficou muito
tímido né não quiseram fazer isso né foi
uma ideia que eu tive tempos atrás
aí mas que nunca foi adiante porque
nunca ninguém quis falar comigo ao vivo
mas se vocês tiverem outras
ideias pra gente mudar um pouco o
formato dessas lives eu ficaria
totalmente aberto
né para
isso
ah Estela mar está dizendo que desse
jeito está ótimo
mas aí vocês podem dar suas opiniões
também
viu bem vamos falar desse artigo que
encontrei aqui sobre as cãimbras e o uso
da vitamina K2 para melhorá-las né Eu
acho que todos nós já sentimos aquela
cra
dolorosa eu sentia antigamente quando Ia
nadar e não fazer um aquecimento direito
mas tem muitas pessoas que TM essas
câmeras quando vão deitar no meio da
noite e faz a pessoa pular da ca
né Então essas câ são muito comuns
especialmente entre os
idosos e muitas vezes até usando
Magnésio e potássio vários desses idosos
não t uma solução definitiva pro
problema aí então esse estudo novo
encontrou resposta com us da vitamina K2
que vocês conhecem que é uma vitamina
importante para evitar a calcificação da
parede das artérias mas usada Nesse
contexto aí de melhorar as câimbras
noturnas Então esse estudo analisou 200
idosos que tinham uma
idade média de idade né Idade Média é
coisa de
eh aula de história né tinham média de
idade de 72 anos esses idosos eles
sofriam de câmeras noturnas leves a
moderadas muitos dos participantes
tinham condições como pressão alta de
diabetes e foram excluídos do estudo
aqueles que tinham doenças metabólicas
graves ou que tinham
eh a característica de tomar os
diuréticos que o diurético aumenta muito
a incidência de de câimbra por conta aí
da deficiência de
potássio A pesquisa foi conduzida ao
longo de oito semanas os participantes
foram divididos em dois grupos um que
recebeu uma dose diária de 180 MG de
vitamina K do tá uma dose um pouquinho
mais alta do que eu passo paraa maioria
dos pacientes na forma de mk7 né que é a
forma que a gente usando dia dia e o
outro grupo tomou um Placebo que é uma
pía de farinha então durante o estudo os
pesquisadores monitoraram a frequência a
duração a intensidade das câimbras
relatadas os resultados foram
interessantes os indivíduos que tomaram
a vitamina K2 tiveram uma redução
significativa na frequência das câimbras
enquanto que o grupo que tomou pilo de
farinha Placebo teve uma média de 3,6
câimbras por
semana e o grupo que tomou C2 teve uma
redução bem grande foi para menos de uma
câimbra por semana então de 3,6 foi para
0,9 então foi mais a redução acima né ou
seja vezes TR né no caso né então
foi três vezes menos mais de três vezes
menos e a melhor ela continuou ao longo
do tempo na última semana do estudo os
participantes do grupo da vitamina K2
tiveram apenas
0,4 episódios de câ Melhorou mais
ainda top né mas os benefícios não
pararam por aí a duração das câmeras
também foi reduzida em 42 minutos E a
intensidade da dor relatada pelos
participantes caiu quase um ponto na
escala de dor Então por causa do por quê
Por causa da melhora do metabolismo do
cálcio tá claro que fk2 melhorou o
metabolismo do cálcio impediu que esse
cálcio ficasse preso no músculo e foi
isso que provocou a melhora das câimbras
né então vamos lá agora você deve estar
se perguntando como é que K2 Age para
reduzir as câimbras eu acabei de falar
isso mas a verdade que não tem uma
resposta
definitiva mas os cientistas acreditam
que isso esteja relacionado à ativação
de prote dependentes de vitamina K como
h6 que desempenha um papel importante na
função do sistema nervoso Então essa
proteína pode ajudar a regular os sinais
neuromusculares evitando os espasmos
Dolorosos que causam as câimbras
embora ess estudo tenha trazido
resultados promissores ainda são
necessários mais pesquisas para
confirmar sees achados vão se vão
permanecer
e entender melhor os mecanismos por trás
desse efeito mas considerando que a K2
também é essencial para saúde ossa e
cardiovascular a suplementação pode ser
uma estratégia promissora para quem
sofre de câmeras frequentes Além do mais
vocês sabem também que a K2 tem ação de
câncer né não é só
isso Beleza então ache isso tudo
interessante achei isso agora
aqui boa
noite travou aqui
travou Boa noite José
Eduardo realmente tá fazendo muito muito
calor né Alice cuidado especial para
esse calor beber muita água ingerir sal
integral sal rosa do Himalaia ou sal
Celta sal marinho
integral comer bastante vegetais que são
rico em minerais né especialmente
abacate que tem bastante
Magnésio
e que
mais alimentação né que a gente sempre
fala mas o principal é comer mesmo Os
Vegetais ricos em vários minerais
diferentes né Essa seria a dica
principal para pra questão do do calor e
colocar um humidificador de ar dentro do
quarto se você tiver num clima mais seco
também
né seria importante
especialmente se você vai ligar o ar
condicionado no quarto para dormir e
deixa o ar muito ressecado né você
coloca umidificador junto ou pelo menos
coloca um balde de água na no quarto
para não pro ar não ficar tão
seco ver se eu acho mais um artigo aqui
interessante pra gente conversar
achei uma coisa interessante aqui no
medscape é uma discussão sobre a Adesão
aos novos medicamentos para obesidade
né que são tão caros ess remédio né eu
fiquei sabendo agora esse final de
semana que
[Música]
o medicamento que não tem no Brasil
Ainda que tá sendo importado tá saindo
mais de r$ 9.000 tratamento
para poucos meses para 2 3 meses no
máximo ão caríssimas as canetas aí
importadas eu tô falando especificamente
aí do monaro
né apesar de serem muito caros e t sido
muito aclamados como revolução do
tratamento do excesso de peso Esses
medicamentos têm sido muito abandonados
no meio né tem muitas pessoas que param
de
tomar e tem três principais motivos
pelos quais os pacientes estão
abandonando essas medicações segundo o
estudo
recente primeiro é que tem a não adesão
à iniciação ou seja tem pacientes que se
negam a Começar o tratamento que eu acho
que é bem aceitável né E eles colocam
que a forma como o médico apresenta esse
medicamento faz toda a diferença se a
prescrição vem acompanhada de culpa ou
vergonha o paciente poderia resistir a
ideia de iniciar o uso por outro lado
quando o médico explica os benefícios
dessas medicações além de perda de peso
como o controle da glicemia melhora da
pressão redução do Risco cardiovascular
o paciente se sente mais confortável
então eles estão dizendo que tem muitos
médicos não estão explicando Essa
questão aí dos ganhos metabólicos né não
é só PDA de peso que melhora o controle
da glicemia melhora da pressão melhora
da função renal
etc Outro fator crítico né que se nós
sabemos é o
custo que os preços Estão realmente
muito
elevados o segundo grande motivo para
interrupção do tratamento é a não adesão
à
implementação isso acontece quando o
paciente até inicia a medicação mas para
antes de alcançar a dose
terapêutica isso pode acontecer porque
os efeitos colaterais não são tolerados
né ou ainda porque os efeitos de
emagrecimento não aparece de imediato
Mas na minha experiência muita gente tem
intolerância as náuseas que causam Esses
medicamentos especialmente a liraglutida
e a semaglutida porque não tem
experiência ainda com a o mon
jaro Então isso é um uma situação que
acontece muito paciente vão fazer mesmo
titulando a dose não tolero a
náusea então o último motivo é a não
adesão persistência Ou seja quando o
paciente abandona uma medicamento após
atingir um certo nível de perda de peso
ou seja ele fica satisfeito com um certo
nível de peso e não quer
continuar aí que vem a visão da Big
Pharma né não é a minha visão essa aqui
segunda a visão da Big Farma esse erro
de parar o u a utilização desse
medicamento
seria um erro porque muitas pessoas vem
esses remédios como uma solução
temporária quando na verdade o
tratamento da obesidade Deveria ser
encarado como de qualquer outra doença
crônica aí vem aquela história nes
querem comparar a obesidade com pressão
alta diabetes que eles acham Já que é
normal e tolerável a pessoa tomar
remédio para resto da vida então eles
querem também criar essa cultura de
tomar as canetinhas do resto da vida
imagina a despesa que é a vida inteira
fica Tom isso
né E eles colocam se for interrompido o
tratamento o peso volta a subir com
certeza se pessa não mudar o estilo de
vida o peso volta a subir
Sim aí a conclusão desse artigo que
podemos aprender com tudo isso primeiro
adesão ao tratamento depende não apenas
do paciente mas também da forma como os
profissionais de saúde orientam e
acompanham esse processo concordo com
esse esse ponto a conscientização sobre
os benefícios manejo adequado doos
efeitos colaterais a expectativa
realista sobre os resultados são
fundamentais para que mais pessoas se
beneficiam dessas medicações
é visão da vifarma
né sobre a K2 essa questão do cálcio em
artérias e válvulas cardíacas deve haver
um vídeo sobre Sim sim eu fiz vídeo
sobre K2 vários vídeos só procurar lá no
canal viu
Jé Como consegue disponibilizar o link
desse estudo qual deles
blandon eu falei de dois aqui esse
último que eu falei aí do das canetas de
obesidade ou primeiro que eu falei da K2
Ah tá aqui estudo sobre as câmeras tá
vou mandar o link para você mas é do
examen.com
tá então pode ser que você não sei se
você vai ter
acesso Mas vamos lá vou mandar o link
achar aqui que eu já saí da
página cara agora não tô achando mais
sumiu
V
aqui
achei vou mandar o link para você aqui
agora
aliás eu vou mandar o link no no grupo
tá vai
ah não F isso não pera
aí tá vou mandar o link do artigo
original mandei no grupo agora
tá tá lá no
grupo
[Música]
ã uma coisa que todos que frequentam
esse grupo são que todos Estão
interessados em melhorar a saúde e
qualidade de vida com certeza
rubri se alguém que quiser mudar o
formato das lives para usuários que
conseguiram vencer alguma condição de
saúde pessoa que fez uma estraté para
vencer o autismo aimoto
etc a gente pode fazer sim a gente pode
fazer lives com temas específicos que
interessem a a vocês tá
ã então o link tá lá viu tá no grupo viu
blandon Dá uma olhada lá no grupo posso
colocar aqui também mas é mais fácil
olhar no grupo né tá aqui
ó mas tá lá no grupo também
tá bem pessoal estamos 45 minutos de
Live Eu acho que eu já respondi todas as
perguntas vou esperar mais um minuto e
encerrar aqui tá bom se vocês tiverem
mais alguma pergunta aí que ficou de
fora
eh
k
bem pessoal vou me despedir de vocês
agradeço tremendamente aí a presença e
as
perguntas nós nos vemos uma semana que
vem E vamos trocando ideia de de repente
fazer umas lives com os temas mais
específicos aí que vocês queiram
discutir tá bom Como foi o caso do
ruberg aqui que ele sugeriu um abraço
até a próxima boa noite